en el vídeo pasado ya platicamos acerca
de qué es el magnetismo lo que quiero
hacer en este vídeo es hablar ahora
acerca de los campos magnéticos y del
efecto que tienen sobre una carga en
movimiento de hecho así es como lo vamos
a definir pero bueno antes de pasar a
ecuaciones y a la definición lo que
vamos a hacer primero es visualizar un
campo magnético para que todas las ideas
queden más fijar para esto de aquí es un
imán voy a dividir el imán en sus dos
polos el de arriba va a ser el polo
norte y el de abajo va a ser el polo sur
y para visualizar el campo magnético lo
que vamos a hacer es trazar algunas
líneas que van a ir de norte a sur eso
de norte a sur es por convención como le
hacemos para saber cómo se ven pues
hacemos lo siguiente mira aquí vamos a
poner un mono polo norte esos no los
hemos encontrado en la naturaleza como
ya lo platicamos pero sí existen
teóricamente entonces vamos a ponerlo
ahí para ver qué pasa entonces ese
monopolio norte se va a empezar a alejar
de este polo norte verdad porque norte
con norte se repelen y poco a poco se va
a ir acercando
al polo sur entonces seguiría más o
menos esta trayectoria si lo ponemos un
poquito más al centro pues primero va a
dar un brinco así más alejado y luego va
otra vez intentar se acercar acá hacia
el polo sur entonces así se vería así
van dando brincos eso es si empezamos
tantito a la derecha si empezamos un
poquito a la izquierda entonces
tendríamos una cosa de este estilo va y
un poquito más al centro pero pero del
lado izquierdo tendríamos una cosa de
este estilo más o menos algo así si no
te gusta esta idea de utilizar mono
polos norte porque son cosas teóricas y
no sabemos muy bien cómo tratarlos
también podemos pensar las cosas como
como que ponemos aquí una brújula
así como que ponemos ahí una brújula y
hacemos que la punta de la brújula la
aguja siempre sea tangente siempre sea
tangente a nuestro campo magnético
entonces si no quería eso entonces nos
quedaría más o menos algo así ahí
tenemos nuestra brújula de este lado
sería el polo norte de la brújula y aquí
sería el polo sur va acuerdate el polo
norte de la brújula apunta hacia el
norte de la tierra baje el norte de la
tierra pero ese es el sur magnético de
la tierra porque el polo norte se atrae
con el polo sur del imán que es la
tierra de hecho ya platicamos mucho de
eso en el vídeo pasado si quieres puedes
ir a ese vídeo para confundirte un
poquito más jajaja eso está bueno
simpático pero ahorita ahorita anda más
la idea de de la cual me quiero acordar
es que norte va hacia sur sur va hacia
el norte y los polos que son iguales se
repelen vale eso es muy parecido a lo
que pasaba en el electrostática donde
las cargas iguales pues se repelían y
las las que eran diferentes se atraían
ahora sí son parecidas la electrostática
y el magnetismo pero hay
a conceptual en el fondo van a ser lo
mismo por una cosa que se llama las
ecuaciones de maxwell pero en la física
clásica si son dos fuerzas diferentes y
la principal diferencia era que el
magnetismo todos son dipolos tienen un
polo norte y un polo sur y en
electrostática puede haber monopolios va
bueno el magnetismo tenemos monopolos
pero nada más teóricos no se han visto
en la naturaleza bueno no vas a decir ok
está muy padre tu dibujo te quedó
sensacional pero esto ya lo había visto
de hecho alguna vez fui a un museo y
puse ralladuras de metal y ya había
visto estas líneas pero ahora sí quiero
saber qué es esto del campo magnético
ahora sí ya formalmente bueno pues vamos
a pasar a eso y eso está bastante más
interesante de hecho un campo magnético
bueno su magnitud su efecto se va a
definir en términos de que le hace a una
carga en movimiento va esto es una pista
de lo que te decía tantito antes de que
en realidad un campo magnético es nada
más un campo electrostático moviéndose a
una alta velocidad una velocidad
relativista o sea que son lo mismo pero
desde puntos de vista distintos desde
marcos de referencia a distintos pero
ahorita no quiero confundir te vamos a
física básica entonces pensemos en que
tenemos un campo magnético ve va
entonces ve va a ser un campo magnético
como son vectores le voy a poner aquí
una flechita vale bueno ya tenemos el
campo magnético entonces lo que sabemos
es que la fuerza en una carga que puede
ser un electrón o un protón o cualquier
otra cosa cargada de hecho esto que voy
a escribir ahorita es lo que utilizan
para para hacer girar las partículas en
luz en estas cosas que son súper
colisionador es que son muy emocionantes
y que hay un pitos bien padres pero
bueno vamos al grano entonces la fuerza
la fuerza que se ejerce sobre una carga
en movimiento va a ser igual a la
magnitud de la carga la magnitud de la
carga multiplicada por y aquí se ponen
interesantes las cosas la velocidad de
la carga producto cruz producto cruz
vale con el campo magnético ok esta
operación la puedes hacer en cualquier
orden bueno porque aquí afuera tenemos
un escalar entonces puedes hacer la
carga por la velocidad cruz con el campo
magnético o sea primero estos dos o bien
primero hacer el producto con su valla
el chiste es hacer el producto cruz de
estos dos y multiplicar por la carga va
bueno aquí esta es la definición y de
aquí ya podemos ver algunas cosas
interesantes verdad porque porque el
producto cruz tiene que ver con la
perpendicularidad de dos vectores como
ya lo habíamos platicado antes entonces
si la velocidad es perpendicular al
campo magnético pues para encontrar la
magnitud de la fuerza nada más hay que
multiplicar estos dos bueno las
magnitudes de estos dos hábitat vamos a
eso pero por otro lado si la velocidad
es paralela al campo magnético entonces
esto va a ser cero y no va a haber nada
de fuerza el campo no afecta a esa
partícula en movimiento vale entonces
para que si haya un efecto necesitamos
tener un cierto ángulo entre la
velocidad y el campo magnético
ahorita vamos a pasar a problemas no
ahorita antes de eso vamos a ver las
unidades porque habitarán se me está
acabando el tiempo y no me daría tiempo
de ver todo un problema así que vamos a
esto de ver las unidades del campo
magnético va para esto lo que vamos a
hacer es sacar la magnitud de ambos
lados de esta de esta igualdad entonces
déjame tomar este color azul entonces
sacando la magnitud de ambos lados
tenemos que la magnitud de la fuerza es
igual a la magnitud de la carga pero
esto ya estaba esto ya era un escalar ya
no hay que ponerle sus barritas de
magnitud entonces que pongo q por la
magnitud de este producto cruz pero como
ya vimos para encontrar la magnitud de
un producto cruz hay que multiplicar las
magnitudes de ambos vectores
y sería la velocidad la magnitud de la
velocidad por la del campo y eso hay que
multiplicarlo por el seno del ángulo
entre b y b muy bien entonces queremos
encontrar las unidades de tevé del campo
magnético cómo le hacemos pues vamos a
analizar esta cosa en unidades que no
detectan pues no tiene unidades este no
le vamos a hacer mucho caso ahorita va
fuerza la magnitud de la fuerza en
newtons en el sistema internacional la
de la carga es tan cool oms la de la
velocidad está en metros por segundo y
la de ve cómo le ponemos bueno pues esto
es lo que queremos encontrar verdad las
unidades de eventos le voy a poner un y
estas son las unidades debe entonces
vamos a despejar be unique para eso y
dividimos ambos lados entre colom por
metro segundo y nos queda newton entre
colom newton entre colom que se pasa
dividiendo por segundo entre metro es
igual a b
las unidades debe el campo magnético muy
bien entonces aquí ya están las unidades
del campo magnético son newtons por
segundo entre colom por metro pero como
te das cuenta está muy difícil de
pronunciar entonces pues afortunadamente
los físicos le pusieron un nombre bonito
en el sistema internacional que tiene
que ver con un físico importante que se
llamaba tesla y justo esto de acá se va
a llamar un tesla vale un
es la entonces un tesla es un newton por
segundo entre colon por metro ok
entonces hábitat ya se me está acabando
el tiempo como para empezar un problema
pero vamos a pensar le tantito te dejo
que lo pienses si hay estamos muy
acostumbrados al magnetismo porque hemos
jugado con imanes pero ahora sí estamos
definiendo los campos magnéticos en
términos del efecto que tiene sobre una
carga en movimiento entonces lo que te
dejo para pensar tantito es por qué
estas unidades reflejan esta idea del
efecto que tiene un campo magnético
sobre una carga en movimiento
bueno piénsalo tantito nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo para empezar con algunos
problemas